have you ever wondered what it feels
like to win an Oscar oh my god
tonight the night of the Oscars I'm
gonna put on a tux and walk around
Hollywood with a fake Academy Award will
I have the greatest night of my life or
most likely what will happen is I'll be
outed and thrown into prison first up we
got to give a little legitimacy to me
winning an Oscar the reason we're here
so we can create like a clip that we can
pull up and say there's proof that's a
fake Oscar I do feel good I'm really a
little bit we'll see what happens
I am having a wonderful night and I was
wondering it's like to get into the
movie I got this for let me find out
good oh my god
thank you guys look at this scene every
movie tonight how you doing tonight yeah
you believe it I can't believe it my
wallet is a theater
you I hope all your dreams come true I
cannot believe this
I just walked away as an Oscar winner I
just got a large orange Gatorade with
free condoms the pleasure pack come
better you go through all right winner
man this is insane we'll watch it bill
I sure thank you so much I'm arrested
not scooter before the bar guy I'd still
go to the hospital in Toronto I just had
a heart-to-heart with our bartender and
chips and salsa empanadas like
appetizers of the one bullsh
I have two glasses of free bourbon no
I'm gonna be in trouble if I do but all
right how much guys I forgot my ID
that's right I can go in thanks man
great job do anybody ladies that was
crazy
a girl gave me your phone number I feel
like I own this town I say that the
invitation you say game imitation a [ __ ]
thank you I lost my ticket
it's not gonna be an issue I saw on the
screen
you did oh my gosh it's crazy she worked
for Oh is there a video this is stop it
Oh
what am I going to do when that big
shows up did you get in for a second
this is it now you reveal are you sure
yeah yeah I don't have any
I'll be your greaser
alright alright let's go
this just got me a free car he's got a
free car I just got a free car why would
you let someone do this I'm driving away
with a stranger's car you don't do that
I don't give your Oscar winner or not I
love a stranger a car just do Wow
this has been an amazing night I did
have to give that car back but it's
still amounted to an amazing night okay
I'm gonna be honest when we started this
I felt a little bad but as the night
went on and everybody was treating me so
nice like I had one of my best nights of
my life tonight being treated very well
I was making a lot of people happy tons
of people are just overjoyed to meet
somebody that had won an Oscar you think
about it most everybody that's really
winning an Oscar tonight is completely
removed from the people that are
watching the event there were people
that now think if anything is achievable
because it's in their world
I want to thank new media rockstars for
getting this all together and giving me
a great night as an Oscar winner if you
like this video and subscribe so you can
see more I hadn't let this girl know
that I wasn't really an Oscar winner I
texted her all I have to tell you
something dot dot kinda didn't win an
Oscar can I do
hi I did the head a new soft lady wanna
be like come down the amerce what she's
expect ha ha I knew it come to my party
ha ha I'm gonna go to this girl's party
you